yes yes that is a sock as a pop filter i
forgot to pack it
at least the audio is better than last
video
why do you always have to complain huh
why you always gotta find something
wrong with everything i'll watch
submissions in the next episode of fly
welcome back to live y youtube favorite
show and yours too i hope
let's review the memes from last week
that you posted that's right
you posted memes i get all the benefits
let's do this you're welcome
you mentioned you like ed sharon so i
got you his new album
saints sainsbury's basics
15 cheesy singles i was your uber driver
like three months ago
that's that this feels too conveniently
set up but i still enjoyed it these are
really important uh
important things all right memes needs
to be authentic and clear
okay goodbye high school i survived
i will never suffer again never
job relationship
no bonus meme
listen guys i know this has been a
problem for a while on the channel
there's been a severe lack of bonus
memes
on this channel for uh i think that
we're on a
three or four week drought of bonus meme
i am trying my best
i am working on it and i think tomorrow
will be a bonus me
i can't promise but i will do my best
updates are ready to install not now my
presentation is in 15 minutes
updates will now be installed please no
your computer will now restart
such a funny meme what the f you even
supposed to do with your hands
while you're getting your oh
meme review it's the only thing you need
to do it actually amplifies the
experience trust me i have
tried meme review makes everything
better where is the bonus me
there's no more time for bonus meme then
stop
showing your chair every minute put some
more chair memes
stop it that meme is dead guys have i
told you about my chat
why are we still here
just to suffer actually guys have i told
you about
my game ass it's coming out on nintendo
game boy check out link in the
description for more info let me see who
you really are
i knew it just wait for the next one
where
they unmask him and it will be me again
and then another one and another one and
you'll be like i'm so creative and funny
and felix is so
unfunny and unoriginal so really ten
steps ahead
at all times just wait for my master
plan to be unwheeled
you will all feel super embarrassed
picture of communism made out of
pictures of you
so fine you know what fight
that was it's funny clever good job
honey timmy which ring
what if grande and dolan is bread
one and bread too
this is just a meme isn't it if the
earth is
flat how come wi-fi look like this
and not like this
i'm glad felix reviewed this meme on
meme review because now it will finally
die thank you felix
hey listen here you scumbag all right
it's not true
i make the memes more popular which
means
they die quicker go
fund me help me get pewdiepie's chair oh
wow all right
begging for money now huh what's next
begging for content
ridiculous it's sort of low life
scumbags
disgust me okay do your own work
zuckerbot activated wireless charging
it's so cute he has to sit on a booster
seat i just love
how this suck memes have just come back
now thanks to this congress video
i just i i want zuck to make one video a
month at least that would just genuinely
make me happier
and make my life so much better thank
you zuck for all the memes we appreciate
you we love you
and we do subscribe to your reptilian
overlord god
oh my god the hypocrisy am i right
this is what i'm talking about memes is
not just to make you haha they're also
made to make you
ma you know what i'm saying does he bite
no but he can hurt you in other ways
your meme actually made it into the y
but brad won
or brad two edited it
that's really who you gotta get past
there's a lot of times i pick
i pick a meme for the thumbnail like
last video and then it's not even in the
edit
and i'm like what the frick guys so
really who you want to impress here it's
not me
it's not reddit it's brad one and two
they're the gatekeepers
what's everyone listening to this
morning spotify
oh my god that is so savage damn just
going against the giant corporation that
will most likely not respond or even see
your message that's insane
the balls the balls of this man woman i
copied pewd's old wall design turned out
quite good
that is actually pretty good pewdiepie
one markiplier one
jacksepticeye 1 total 3
subscriber 61 subscriber
20 subscriber
my 8. guys
hey brad one or two please edit out this
meme
so they don't find out about the chair
overlord conspiracy
thank you
[Music]
i'm yours i love you marcia i love you t
he's lying he said the same thing to
brad what the mark
zucker the suck meme has just taken over
the fbi meme now is that how we're doing
then
i like it keep it up proud of you am i
pregnant
uploaded nine months ago
it's pretty aesthetic honestly well done
just just look at the flowers see you
guys should thank me
for reviewing the memes okay some some
memes just needs to die
and you should all be thanking me and
the reason isn't because i
i reviewed it it's because i gave it a
zero that's right
a meme getting a zero review means it's
instant death
okay cnn dramaalert fish news
wii news pure news that's right
everybody
the most trusted legitimate news source
on the internet got the highest rating
of approval from
everyone literally everyone said it
thank you guys for supporting
independent news developer our whole
team is
working really hard here to get the the
facts and nothing but the facts
god damn it
is it really that bad in the back
i honestly didn't even know god damn it
pewdiepie an indian newspaper with
headline plays video games
all day long and now earns millions per
year
wow is it 2013 yet anyone
bravo india you really keeping the
curves man
damn in china youtube is blocked so
someone makes
sure to re-upload every pewdiepie video
to yooku
not all heroes wears capes yeah wow what
a hero that steals all my revenue huh
what kind of low-life degenerate scumbag
will take someone else's content and
monetize it
huh you tell me leave your entries in
[Music]
it has eyes
i am shaking
no i'm so done i'm legit
i'm done this is this is legit from my
video
this is the second time it happened last
time there was a vagana
now there's straight up a girl having
the sex success
the fbi meme just became so much better
thanks to the sucker
reskin or whatever to call it i love it
it's so cute
h3 all right do we have time for bonus
oh meat god oh my god
oh i have a feeling this week guys i
have a strong
hunch okay cannot confirm cannot confirm
but i have a good feeling this week
might be the week
i can't fit bullying into the video
bullying pewdiepie
or can i
it's really great it's really great
having people working for you really
doing their best to make you look the
best at all times thank you guys
really appreciate it the reason there is
no bonus meme is because of brad
that's right everybody you really
shouldn't be talking to me about this
this is completely out of my
be hands guys we done it get well soon
gennady the whole squad fam is with you
oh
that's that's amazing honestly thanks to
everyone that donated that's really
really cool and impressive of you guys
[Music]
do
it's gonna say your mom gay or something
i'm so dumb oh you're like seriously you
don't need ad block if you only watch
pewdiepie clearly just go to the chinese
version they are way better ads they're
actually quite enjoyable
the space we see inside pewdiepie's
closet
actual space inside pewdiepie's closet
that's it's got good room in here pretty
good echo
i'm actually quite comfortable and the
top meme everybody
he is being exposed i didn't do anything
come on
please believe me it's your daughter's
birthday for god's sake
how did you know that
the suck meme has come back and it's as
glorious as ever
thank you guys for another episode of
lawyer great memes
great times next one we're gonna have a
little theme around
brad and and brad too so do
keep an extra attention to those so
maybe your memes in the description
i mean in the reddit and remember to
leave a thumbs up
and share with everyone that you know
ever leave your entries in the subreddit